9 now 4k Felder Hill the last player I
can remember doing it on a regular basis
Lindsay huh
I saw changed the shot defensive list
they took him for the upside got a big
upside they left rogdon that was a bust
[Music]
Brockton in public policies
he reminds them of our
we'll work on November 1st is the wallet
I may have sat out of 3/4 vote the best
yep
take away Brogdon back to a four-point
game
but ro got deep position early they're
gonna run off and get an easy one out of
it the Pels may mean either timeout
pressure here down the stretch with the
game in the balance robbed and spinning
left head
malcolm in the middle again things are
looking lights out based on what they've
done so far eurasian season that's a
nice play by the rookie malcolm brogdon
short on that check you've done a bunch
a head
transition basketball first time for
everything but you had a wide open
blogged in a wide-open bar on that side
[Applause]
where he's gonna be without having to
see him a little wrap around number two
getting around the body of Asha quit
LeBron off to a quick start back to her
car nicely done often gets it over
beautiful gentle let's just gotta play
even would please Linda win this game
rock band meeting like us
the Bucks they'll have had all the
answers tonight they responded in big
way
free the Bucks led by 9 after 1 it was
tied at the half bragdun little body
English coaxing that triple down easily
sealed that's a great pass Brockton
circle around and check back through it
again acknowledged only played away from
basketball what a pass puts it in the
perfect pocket does all the little
things for your team to win and he was
the only acc player to be Defensive
Player of the Year and player of the
year Bulls is up around 33% the best of
his career flashed that he wants to load
those up get in his grill
[Applause]
that's a lucky ladies and gentlemen the
Brockton they gathered by rear me and
there's the stair
too hard to offer in defending corner
threes that's a pretty good mix it sure
is and shooting them it supposes
[Applause]
he does not look at LeBron James that
for that hat it's really unforced also
too bad after this is the duck but
bloggers look at that Jim it's a [ __ ]
up
that is impressive force just enough of
an off balance situation for Taj Gibson
looked like he was going to make that
shot Brockton hits a three that'll help
him get a little more comfortable in his
own skin on a D Wade saving an offensive
rebound putback and Brogdon here just
kind of simple there's the rebound and
here comes Jabari Parker when rowing
front Brogdon running flush timeout
Chicago 939 remaining in the fourth
quarter instead of just moving the ball
around at the rim everybody had to put
it on the floor just one obligatory time
was unnecessary the three ball Oh catch
and shoot and Simmons is a point forward
type of a players I could handle the
ball
would that come from but plays like this
and that's called Duncan on somebody
Nerlens Noel goes up for the challenges
you see Braga and give it a little bit
of the doctored a boost off the left
shoulder with his left arm and straight
hard right side just looking a jump in
the air which is another taboo back in
the day I love the the mindset of this
team I'm just kind of taking care of
business and then I'll say kind of act
like you've been there before it's a
dump you know you could pose a little
bit but don't get overly enthused
[Music]
much taken away again Jason Terry
Brogdon three bring it
and that brings a timeout girl Watson
takes it for Phoenix malcolm brogdon
pretty good-looking rookie Michael I
agree
and on the shack block - fix it on pass
intended for dang in the quarter pass
ahead
beautifully done for Brightman peach
bars have run
and then watch there it is steel and
what's how powerful Brogdon is I mean he
is just powerful and quick as well with
it great use of the body look at him
turn right there yep that shields the
ball and draws the foul a great time to
talk to Kareem with the way the game was
going I might add
I guess perfect time per quarter
since we have seen lately for Michael
Beasley who was not available tonight
with a hyper-extended left me suffered
in Cleveland on Monday night yes
[Music]
[Applause]
Middleton's at that time wagon quick
move looks fresh off the glass Montreux
and won the Bruce brothers back at it
eating off each other and once again
penetration you see the crowd that
brought in attracts and it wasn't a
corner three that's a tough tough
delivery 34 straight games adding to his
career long streak rogdon three and he
gets tripped up after making that by
Tony Allen no whistle on that
inadvertent trip
oz is pretty unflappable better pitch in
[Applause]
from Delhi delay game warning one of the
mana backdoor play Jim and basket
our producer dan keener just said here's
the pass to brought them
[Applause]
Bragdon knows how to fitters
a lot of basketball was going to do this
the first couple of weeks of camp
[Applause]
leggins got it
you take this little two on one action
nice job
[Music]
[Applause]
once in a while
Bronte when the top [ __ ] producing
teams in the league with the Bucks
matching them with the play of the
president Malcolm Brogdon throwing it
down Russian take a bad shot
[Applause]
Alec birthmarks is that is average
beautiful Malcolm Brogdon it's another
hand one for the box did little high
screen little hawk cut what step Carters
in the right hand voluntarily a turnover
Westbrook Malcolm right there you go
I felt that one coming woohee jammed
nothing saw the lane and then just took
off on him I started shooting every time
I was open he helped me understand that
[Applause]
[Music]
there's the double on the bounce
right on the shot clock he drains the
three rocket to the rain and a foul
laughs step jam
Yanis reaches at bat and touch
controlled by a hansen Dellavedova pass
ahead a beautiful pass ahead that was
bribed him to go get it and it led him
behind the defense Monroe the rebound he
goes to Ulis who loses the dribble
Malcolm Brogdon three on one hands
hello it's a two point this job on the
defensive end good decision by Malcolm
Brogdon gets it over to sterling Brown
plenty of time yet
Rocketship's just under two minutes now
the first pocket badness and one
off balance and play through contact
you heard it here
[Applause]
[Music]
to the 10 zone and Owen has mastered
that the old but face last minute race
to the opposite face line clinic a big
bit let's up a bind this block and come
back well the way this team is
constructed he can have an off nice the
Bucks could still win and maybe win big
nice job the peasants what's he got to
do get it get it up there
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
we double teams down in the post clipper
turnover Malcolm Brogdon drives Gortat
he gets by him to score well done he's
done a great job of that
Mike's kinda three-point shooter just
missed one for the Clippers Brogdon sees
that opening and takes Malcolm Brogdon
little change of pace right the dude
there's a change the piece right there
just enough that hesitation no walk he
leads by one them primed in 63 59 shot
big nice job penetrating you see the
deep it's over commit too long of a run
for Monte Morris take that which into
halftime and wait frankly I think
everybody wondered if Creek defense
Brogdon and Lopez there somebody got a
hands on it Brogdon now
[Applause]
by a Turkish the differential between
the game and shot clock at 6 seconds
Wetzel Brogdon
yes
ready to shoot knows the time on the
clock it's that one to go but 18% come
free have the basket by Brogdon it's an
and-one Green finds the open three-point
shooters Malcolm Brogdon tie game
let take the shot Middleton making the
right play getting in the paint finding
the open shooter Malcolm
[Music]
Bragdon steady diet of going to the
basket this time for a fashionable
three-point play this cavalier defensive
unit Jim laughs in the league in terms
of defensive field goal percentage
[Music]
[Applause]
he was way behind er it's a hot potato
underneath and it's brown who comes up
with the fumble pass
led to 16 Milwaukee points two for one
opportunity here
Ilyas over you get
[Applause]
[Music]
Brogdon
[Applause]
walking in the first on the lawn at the
University of Virginia he can live
anywhere he wants now
[Music]
Lopez go to stick hand
haha Justine Augustine's picked this
watch at Brogdon about Charles Lee
getting his wish in August and Bledsoe
with a deuce
four seconds on a timer Compton Rajan
great rock that hits it three trip was
made by Milwaukee in the overtime of the
rags and fat cats in here double team
kick-out Jack clock winding down and see
it through for one opportunity for the
Bucks
draw it in splash
[Applause]
[Music]
Yanis no hesitation off the front on the
three-point attempt
Payton has taken away Yanis laying have
no clue smoke pit
there's math in this country I had just
died although his job Yanis tony snell
sounds like somewhere
dyrus part times my tapley has career
[Applause]
probably the waterfall
we stepped away what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content